that we need to go 3d in cities in order  to alleviate traffic congestion and i  think probably the best way to do that  is with  uh with tunnels yes tunnels the other  day i went i went down the street and  down into a hole in the ground and  actually gone on a subway  i was amazed i thought did he was elon  here did he put the subway system  in my city like i googled  and i looked and turns out  you had nothing to do with that actually  that was there for that's been there for  like a hundred years  i don't  i don't i don't know i don't mean to  make fun  uh unfairly my boss put me up to that a  little bit  um  but uh there's a grain of truth to that  right  like  you want i mean you get i knew i could  riff with you because you're that  you're riff you like to riff  you did snl um so twitter